gonna make that delicious Korean cheese
corn that you get at Korean BBQ there's
a bunch of different ways to make it but
today we're really going to Sauce this
thing up starting by stripping some
fresh corn feel free to use canned or
frozen corn transfer to a large mixing
bowl add in mozzarella and mayonnaise
which is totally optional a little bit
of sweetener I'm using monk fruit
sweetener and some garlic salt and black
pepper to taste mix this all up and make
sure everything is nicely Incorporated
now I'm going to grab my oven safe
Skillet butter it up and don't forget
the sides transfer your corn mixture
into the oven at 400 for like 15 to 20
minutes I was supposed to incorporate
some chopped green onions into the
mixture but totally forgot so I'm
chopping them up now and I'm just going
to sprinkle them on top along with some
more mozzarella cheese and we're going
to broil it for about three minutes
the way the juice bursts out the corn is
so good especially mixed with the Tang
from the QB you seriously have to try
this